catching fire is that the game sequ the
second one yeah you like do you like
being an actor I do actually what I like
about it is that it's not about me it's
about a character and a director's
vision and I get to collaborate with all
these people CU you know like you said
normally I'm in the studio by myself or
with one or two people did you take
acting lessons no but I used to act when
I was a kid right yeah oh you your blood
youw up around it it's also an
interesting thing because that's you
know like one of those beloved
franchises and your character is I mean
I had no idea what that thing was going
to be I got the director of the first
one Gary Ross saw precious and based on
that he hired me to play C uhhuh and he
gave me the role there was no audition
he just I was in the Bahamas he called
me and said I want you to play this role
in Hunger Games I didn't know what the
hell Hunger Games was uhhuh did you
audition for uh precious no no so that's
kind of cool that you don't have AUD
audition for nothing really yeah so how
do people know to approach you to be an
actor when you weren't primarily acting
well Lee Daniels is the first guy that
took the took the the chance and and and
casted me in that um he in Precious I
wasn't I was I would never have done
this really yeah right and uh were you
shocked when you get a call out of the
blue for somebody to say he met me at a
restaurant uh we were at Mr Chows and he
was having dinner with Julian Schnabel
right and I knew Julian for years the
artist yeah who actually offered me the
role of Basia back back when he did that
movie um before he casted uh Jeffrey
yeah Jeffrey um but at that time I
didn't want to play somebody else I was
just becoming me you right and I knew a
lot of Jean Michelle's people and I just
anyway I didn't end up doing it but um
Lee came up to me and said you should be
acting I feel you should be in movies
and wow he said come do this thing and
okay I did it you know kind of a charm
life right Lenny it it's a it's a
blessing yeah it really is crazy that
that happened and Hunger Games you
weren't aware of the book I guess the
book was a deal I got I got the book and
I read it and I thought it was was
really good storytelling I thought it
was captivating I read the whole book
and when the movie came out did you go
to the premiere is that the first time
you saw the movie well I I I got a clue
when we were shooting in North Carolina
and kids were waiting out in front of
the hotel with the books and I thought
this is kind of odd the movie is not
even shot right right that's what I was
going to get to CU this is a whole
different kind of thing for you in terms
of recognition and publicity and does
does that bring you a new audience to
your music as well oh it's brought a lot
of a lot of young kids
yeah